hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and today I will
be breaking down the latest developments
in the attack on Titan story and I don't
have to tell you that the story has been
blowing up in recent chapters most of
the time quite literally a ton of very
important events took place in a very
short period of time in this latest
chapter including the epic return of two
major characters I mean I knew they
would both come back I've been saying it
in video after video but it was still
amazing to see it actually happen and
the plot continues to thicken so let's
get into it
if you enjoyed the attack on Titan
content on this channel and you'd like
to see more please leave a like to let
me know and if you happen to be new to
anime please don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you can also check
us out on twitch twitch TV slash anime
uproar where we do regular manga
discussions including for attack on
Titan and we are now making all of our
videos available in audio format as a
podcast if that's something you'd be
interested in you can check out anime up
or audio on Spotify Apple podcasts or
wherever you get your podcasts links in
the description
finally this video will of course
contain attack on Titan manga spoilers
we're talking about the most recent
events in the story so please proceed
with caution
you have been warned chapter 1 to 5
starts off with a very clear message
the rumbling that was initiated by Eren
created a lot of collateral damage the
wall Titans didn't just quietly emerge
and begin their mission to protect all
the audience on the island on the
contrary the sudden destruction of the
walls has claimed the lives of many
innocent people in the island who were
trapped under the rubble or trampled by
the Titans themselves the soldiers are
doing their best to rescue as many
civilians as possible and our girl hitch
is there among the soldiers trying to
help the victims of the rumbling I'll be
honest and say that I kind of forgot
that hitch was still around but good for
her for still being alive and fighting
the good fight
the aftermath of the rumbling to
competing opinions have emerged about
Aaron some people are outraged that
Aaron activated the rumbling and killed
so many of his own people as a result of
collateral damage but others consider
the loss of those people unnecessary
sacrifice in order to protect everyone
else on the island from Total
Annihilation the situation is dire and
the two factions are fighting amongst
themselves so hitch is charged with
going back to headquarters and bringing
the new recruits and weapons into the
streets in order to help maintain order
and prevent violent riots from breaking
out the focus on collateral damage was
relatively brief but it is such an
important aspect of the attack on Titan
story and something that separates
attack on Titan from many other series
when Aaron first initiated the rumbling
I didn't even consider that this would
cause widespread collateral damage and
take out a bunch of innocent people I
was focused on the bigger picture the
war against Marley and the other foreign
nations and the need to protect paradise
from these enemies the whole idea behind
the rumbling was that Aaron wanted to
protect the people of paradise against
cruel and persistent attacks by foreign
invaders Aaron and his comrades had
tried everything to make peace and avoid
future conflict but conflict kept
knocking on their door whether they
liked it or not with that in mind it is
possible to understand how Aaron might
have come to the conclusion that the
only way to protect his friends and
everyone he cares about is to initiate
the rumbling but war always has
unintended consequences and collateral
damage war is no joke war cannot be
perfectly planned or controlled and in
any war the biggest losers are always
the innocent civilians who get caught up
in the middle through no fault of their
own this is why I truly appreciate the
attack on Titan story and how realistic
and nuanced it is in most other series
the focus is on the main characters and
on the big picture
and when epic stuff happens including
massive explosions and transformations
and battles we don't usually spend any
time thinking about the effect that such
explosions and transformations would
have on random innocent civilians who
have nothing to do with
main plot but attack on Titan does take
the time to point out these important
details the story reminds us that every
action has consequences and even if you
do something with the noblest of
intentions your actions can still cause
destruction and suffering Eren felt that
he had no choice but to initiate the
rumbling in order to protect everyone
that he cares about on the island but
even though his goal was a noble one
from the perspective of the Islanders
innocent people still suffered and died
because you can't just destroy three
gigantic walls without having tons and
tons of rubble raining down on all the
people and property below back at the
military headquarters hitch notices a
trail of some sort of liquid substance
on the floor she follows the trail into
what looks like a library where she
comes face-to-face with none other than
an Elan heart the recently
uncrystallized annie grabs hit from
behind and threatens to kill her if she
makes a sound
however hitch manages to overturn the
situation by flipping annie around and
slamming her to the ground
annie is far weaker than she used to be
after spending over four years inside
the crystal I'm sure she will recover
eventually but at this point she is
apparently as strong as an old woman
however even though she is clearly weak
and he may still be capable of
transforming into the female Titan
hitch is suspicious about whether Annie
even has the energy to transform at this
point in time but in the end she doesn't
want to take the risk if annie chooses
to transform she will destroy the
headquarters and kill a lot of innocent
recruits in the process so hitch agrees
to just help Annie escape the city as
hitch is preparing the horses annie
reveals that she was indeed conscious or
at least semi-conscious during the time
that she was sealed away inside the
crystal she compares it to having a
faint dream but she does recall hearing
the voices of hitch and Arman in the
distance Annie
also heard Aaron's telepathic
communication to all LD ins once they
hop on a horse and begin to travel
outside of the city and he can see for
herself that Aaron was indeed serious
about
destroying the world the rumbling has
taken place and endless hordes of wall
Titans are marching in formation towards
the ocean hitch tells Annie to look at
the collateral damage that the rumbling
and the colossal Titans have caused and
she asks Annie again how she could have
done what she did in her own Titan form
back in the past when the female Titan
fought against eren's Titan inside the
Capitol all those years ago there was
also a ton of collateral damage and many
innocent people died hich doesn't
understand how Annie could be okay with
doing things like this how she can live
with herself after causing so much
destruction and misery but Annie
explains that as someone who grew up in
Marly she was taught to see the world in
a completely different way from hitch as
she trained to become a warrior
and he just like Reiner and Gabi and all
the other warriors were actively
encouraged to kill LD ins on the island
they were taught to see all the
Islanders not as fellow human beings but
as evil devils who had to be killed for
the sake of saving the world according
to this propaganda the Islanders were
evil they threatened the safety of
everyone else in the world and for this
reason killing them indiscriminately was
completely justified in fact killing the
evil Islanders was their duty it wasn't
even a matter of choice it was a matter
of obligation this is the part that
people who just blindly hate Reiner
Annie and Gabby don't quite understand
since we as the readers and viewers
experienced the story from the point of
view of the Islanders we sympathize with
them and we see the marlins as evil and
I would definitely argue that what the
Marlins are doing is objectively evil
but it's very difficult to know that you
yourself are doing something evil if
you've been taught for your entire life
that the evil thing you are doing is
actually good think of it as being part
of a cult for outsiders it's hard to
imagine why anyone would allow
themselves to be manipulated by a cult
but for the people inside the cult who
have been brainwashed manipulated lied
to and mentally and physically abused
from a very young age they eventually
get to a point where they don't know
right
wrong in such an environment it is easy
to manipulate people into doing evil
things because they genuinely don't know
any better they've been brainwashed and
I would definitely compared to Marlon
warrior program to a cult in some ways
the Warriors are victims just as much as
they are villains they are recruited at
a very young age while they are still
just impressionable children they are
lied to and manipulated constantly their
entire families are held hostage at the
mercy of the merlion military and all of
these factors together contribute to
their life choices some of the things
they've done are certainly inexcusable
but it's hard to just label them as
villains without considering the
specific context in which they did what
they did
we then finally get more of Annie's
backstory and we learn additional
information about Annie's relationship
with her father it turns out that Annie
was abandoned by her mother as a baby
after a blood test determined that her
mother's lover was secretly an LD --it
this is interesting because it suggests
that the mother did not know that the
lover was an LD and before the baby was
born so it is possible that the lover
was able to hide his LD n identity
through some falsified blood tests much
like the owl
Ehren Kruger did although if you're
thinking that Ehren Kruger might be
Annie's real father the timeline doesn't
add up unless Annie lied about her age
she would have been born several years
after Aaron Kruger was already eaten by
Grisha Yeager inside the internment Zone
and he was adopted by an LVN man who
apparently came from abroad at first
Annie's adoptive father's only goal was
to train Annie to become the best
possible warrior his plan was to benefit
from the honorary Marlon Citizenship and
the other perks that he would receive if
his daughter succeeded in joining the
warrior program eventually Annie became
as strong as her adoptive father wanted
her to be and she was able to overpower
him despite the fact that she was a
little girl and he was an adult man and
he succeeded in joining the warrior
program but before she departed for the
mission on Paradise Island Annie's
father knelt before her and apologized
for all the suffering he had put her
through with his training he
come to view Annie is more than just an
opportunity to lead a better life he
came to view her as his own daughter
and he told her to forget everything
forget the honorarium our land status
the title of warrior and everything else
the only thing that should matter to her
now was surviving and coming home safe
Annie took this advice to heart
she was never ideologically motivated or
brainwashed by the Merlin's like say a
Reiner was she knew that she had a
father waiting for her at home and she
just wanted to come back to him one day
even if that meant doing terrible things
she recognizes that she committed
horrible sins in the past but she says
that she'd do it again if it means
getting back home to her father this is
an important point that Annie makes our
actions in life are a matter of
perspective
it all depends on how we frame our
actions and our experiences Annie lived
a hard life she was abandoned by her
parents she was oppressed constantly and
the only person who ever showed her any
affection was her adoptive father so she
wasn't really worried about the rest of
the world she wasn't thinking about the
well-being of some random strangers that
she never meant and that never did
anything for her she decided that the
only thing that matters was surviving
and coming home to her father
and she would do whatever it takes to
accomplish this goal the safety and
well-being of random strangers on the
island was not her concern especially
after she was told that they were all
evil Devils having said that it is clear
that Annie does regret her actions and
that once she saw that the people in the
island weren't evil she didn't want to
harm them this is most evident by her
reaction to the death of Marco
so her perspective shifted over time but
it isn't hard to understand how Annie
must have felt at the beginning when she
first arrived on the island back in the
lab aerial internment Zone the LD ins
there are trying to alert the Marlin
guards about Aaron's ominous telepathic
message but the Marlins of course did
not hear Aaron's voice so they're not
buying it
and they think that the aliens are just
lying in order to escape the camp the
soldiers begin attacking the LD ends
enforcing
to their knees but the ldiots don't have
much to lose at this point they know
that if they stay where they are right
now they're gonna be killed anyway as
soon as Aran arrives so Annie's dad
thinks back to the promise that Annie
made him to come back one day and he
decides to fight against the Marlin
guard and he grabs at the guards gun it
appears that an elder in rebellion in
Liberia may be happening but we don't
get to see more of those events because
the story shifts back to the island some
of the new recruits are trying to tell
shadows to escape since the Jaeger ist's
are taking control of the fortress and
shadows is a symbol of the old regime
but shyness explains that he doesn't
intend to run and he tells the recruits
not to oppose the Jaeger ists most of
the population seems to be on their side
and they will definitely seize control
of the island soon supposing them would
be like suicide for the recruits
meanwhile Armin and weakest are speaking
about potentially stopping Kony from
feeding falco to his mother's titan
armin is worried that even if aaron
succeeds in destroying the world while
protecting the aliens on the island if
they can't gain the trust of falco Gabi
Reiner and Peake then the history of the
Titan Wars will just repeat itself the
Warriors will form their own faction on
the island and the Titan shifter
infighting will continue even after
Aaron destroys the rest of the world
Armin ultimately decides to go after
Kony and to tell him to leave his mom as
she is this is undoubtedly very
difficult for him to do but in the end
he feels that this is what has to be
done for the good of humanity
the history of the world and of mankind
is about to change drastically thanks to
Aaron's actions and they have to make
the best of what they have left
Mikasa isn't sure what to do when she
asks Armin what they're going to do
about Aaron
but Armin tells her that he doesn't know
and that she needs to think for herself
right now they are in a very difficult
position
Eren is out there destroying the walls
and the world
hanji and Levi might be dead flock and
his men are trying to take control of
the military and Annie could also be
there somewhere just waiting to turn
into
a female Titan the current situation on
the island is a state of complete chaos
because the government and the chain of
military command have broken down and no
one is safe not even Queen história the
situation is critical and they simply
don't have time to think about Aaron
right now after all Aaron is a massive
Titan monster and he is controlling
millions of wall Titans there isn't much
that they can do about Aaron now even if
they wanted to so they have to focus on
what they can do and that is preserving
some semblance of order here on the
island arm and then starts complaining
how her win should have been saved
instead of him but come on our man get
over it man you are out here telling me
Casa that you don't have time to think
about Aaron and yet you in like the next
breath are talking about how our win
should have been saved instead of you it
is what it is Arman and you are an
amazing strategist so let's get to work
my dude
as Arman leaves Mikasa notices that her
scarf is gone Gabi then says goodbye to
kya and her family and she heads out on
horseback with Arman in order to
intercept Falcon Connie before Coney
feeds falco to his mother
elsewhere Jean walks in on flock
torturing some of the volunteers who
came to the island in order to fight
against marl a flock claims to be a
confidant of Aaron and he says that
Aaron told him his master plan 10 months
ago and apparently the plan was to use
Zeke and then betray him in order to
gain the power of the founding Titan
this definitely isn't total BS that
flock just came up with on the spot or
anything flock being the genius-level
strategist that he is tells the
volunteers that their homelands are
about to be destroyed and that they have
nothing left to live for but hey if they
want to serve the audience and fire then
that would be dope I can't imagine a
worse way to try to motivate someone to
help you these guys came to the island
to risk their lives in a war against
Marley and flock is like oh okay guys so
you and your countries are screwed and
now I'm going to torture you but hey you
know join us and stuff one of the
volunteers that flock was torturing
speaks up against him but flock just
shoots him and kills him he then uses
the
man is an example for the other
volunteers and tells them that there is
no reason for anyone else to die as long
as they obeyed the will of the glorious
King Emperor flock Forster the proud
owner of the most stylish bangs on
parody's Mikasa shows up and she and
Jean are like flock buddy are you ok man
what's going on with you at this point
flock sounds like some kind of crazy
zealot and he has taken it upon himself
to cleanse the island of hatred while
Aaron cleanses the rest of the world he
seems to think that after he gets rid of
everyone he doesn't like on the island
while Aaron gets rid of everyone off the
island then they will all finally be
free to live whichever way they want to
live I mean ok I can understand how
someone who grew up in that cruel world
and served as a soldier for all those
years could lose it like this but I'm
willing to bet that Aaron doesn't give a
damn about flock and he probably never
even told him his plan and let's face it
Aaron isn't the only one I bet that no
one out there watching or listening to
this right now literally no one gives a
damn about flock and if you see that one
guy in the comments saying flock is best
boy I love his best genius hairstyle and
so on you can be certain that they're
just memeing nobody loves flock nobody
moving on
Mikasa asks the legendary King Emperor
flock where han Jie and Levi are and he
tells them that they were both killed by
Zeke again definitely 100% not total BS
meanwhile falco is riding with Kony on
horseback Kony is telling Falco that he
lost his memory and Kony is just trying
to take him to the hospital although in
reality he wants to feed him to his
mother well I can appreciate a son
wanting to prepare a hot meal for his
mother every once in a while I think
corny will end up changing his mind
although he may not even get the chance
to change his mind because falco is
already thinking about somehow bitching
Kony and heading back south to meet up
with Gabi and the others as all of this
is happening and as you can see a lot is
happening in all sorts of different
locations at the same time we also see
Peake and McGrath watching the wall
Titans marched towards the sea as the
Marlin airships rushed back to the
continent the airships are trying to get
back and warn everyone about the
rumbling and Peake asks
if the Marlin military has any way to
stop Aaron magatha says no there's
really nothing that they can do except
hold out until the very end but then
suddenly the two of them are approached
by Han Jie han Jie puts her hands up and
tells them that she is unarmed she also
points to a wagon behind her where an
injured man is wrapped up in bandages
and lying down motionless han Jie says
that the man inside the cart is a
completely harmless man who failed to
die and the text on the final page says
that a soldier shall not die until he
has given meaning to his life just as I
thought and just as a lot of you thought
Levi is injured but he is indeed alive
there is no way that an absolute mad lad
like Levi would die in such a random and
off-screen way not after everything he's
been through how ironic is it that Han
Jie called them completely harmless
absolutely hilarious
it's true that this chapter didn't have
any epic Titan battles but it had a ton
of moving parts we saw a bunch of
different scenes playing out at
different locations at the same time
including a knee and hitch the audience
rebelling at Lee Barry Oh Armin and
Mikasa king-emperor flock Han Jie and
Levi so much is happening I feel like
all the chess pieces are being moved
into place before we get to the final
showdown although it is difficult to say
what precise form this final showdown
will take personally I am very happy
that Annie and Levi are back and call me
crazy but I predict that flock will not
make it to the end of the story now I
really hope that the next chapter will
give us more Erinn and in particular I
want to know more specifics about his
new Titan form after he transformed
we've been seeing pretty much everything
else that's been happening except for
Aaron himself so I hope this changes in
the next chapter let me know what you
guys think are you hyped for the return
of Annie and Levi and how do you think
that the two of them are going to affect
the story going forward is Levi too
injured to play an important role
anytime soon
or is he maybe bluffing and he's not
quite as injured
it appears also is any too weak right
now to transform into the female Titan
or is she going to actually attempt to
fight Eren again in her Titan form feel
free to hit me up down in the comments
if you enjoyed this video you want to
see more attack on titan content right
here on the channel please leave a like
to let me know it really does help and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
please don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't go through
the trouble of clicking the bell and
selecting the option that says all
notifications you're gonna miss a lot of
our videos that's just how YouTube works
you can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar I want to give
a massive thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who support the channel
and make what we do possible with all
the problems on YouTube lately patron
support means more than ever so thank
you guys so much special thanks to all
of our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson Kings Eldred very dolla
beat Anatole kazansky alpha do on hell
crews and team Sparky 65 and I can't
forget the ones who rise above all other
clans a huge thank you to all of our the
one tier patrons including in grata
alone Adam Maddy Mac makoto-kun the
world Steelers the school bus and Tyson
Queenie no if you enjoy our content and
you feel we provide value for you please
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]